[Music]
welcome to the first episode of our new
quiz show we pulled a bunch of geeks and
we asked them to pick their favorite
giant monsters in the history of movies
and I have in my hand the results of our
survey and I'm going to give you four
chances to guess what our respondents
picked what is your first guess
King Kong King Kong was one of the picks
yeah congratulations but I'm gonna have
to give you 0 points because you did not
specify which version of King Kong what
we're talking about the original 1933
version of King Kong for all I know
you're talking about King Kong from that
awful 70s Dino De Laurentiis movie zero
zero point zero nothing
that's what I thought second guess the
alien which alien the alien from alien
he means the xenomorph from the original
1979 ridley scott alien no coaching the
xenomorph from the original ridley scott
alien wrong
what fail zero points that was a great
movie monster but it was about seven
feet tall by no stretch of the
imagination was that a giant movie
monster you're barely a giant monster
now
the Queen xenomorph from aliens 20 feet
tall that is a giant movie monster that
would have earned you points but as it
is
no nothing zero points there's a crappy
game you are a crappy contestant you're
a crappy host I'm gonna rise above that
and we're gonna move on third guess
Godzilla from the original 1954 film
Godzilla from the original 1954 Godzilla
okay Godzilla of course was on our list
yeah hooray but you get zero points what
what everybody knows that the best
Godzilla suit ever was from destroy all
monsters in the late 60s Oh doc destroy
this Latin classified Nerdist I'm Graham
- oh yeah
baseball hurry I'm allergic to nerds
that's disgusting
good luck explain to your wife why
you'll smell like giant creature it's an
aphrodisiac don't worry about it
I'm docking you ten points you now have
negative ten points totally worth it
this game is ridiculous hey take it up
with our poll respondents I bet you only
told yourself you are 0 for 3 we're
going into the final round you've gotten
everything wrong but you still have one
chance to redeem yourself you win the
game if you can pick the number one
response what is the greatest giant
monster in movie history me what me
you're not even in a movie yes he is
he's the star of the upcoming film giant
monster stomps on bad ball obnoxious
dude coming soon to a theater near you
no no no yes you are
trust me I'm going to allow that that's
close enough
we have a winner we have a winner giant
creature I win do I get to step on him
now check out the wired channel the
scene calm for the entire giant creature
series